[音楽]
[拍手]
こんにちは
慶應義塾女子高等学校2年の溝口です私は
小学6年から中学3年までの間をアメリカ
で過ごし高校から女子高に入学しましたで
は私がなぜ女子校を選んだのか
キラキラしてるからかっこいいから
私が思考を選んだ一番大きな理由とは大学
へのだいぶ進学があるところですそれでは
ライブ進学の利点とは何でしょうか
自由に時間を使えること勉強しなくていい
こと私はこう考えています
大学史大学内部進学が
移転とは
高校3年間の間を大学受験にとらわれず
自由に使えるということです
時間とはどんなにお金があってもお金で
買うことはできずまた均等に24時間1日
24時間は
全員に均等に与えられています
今日は私のロボコンチームでの経験ボイス
カードでの経験またアメリカで中学時代を
過ごした経験を交えて私が私なりにどの
ように高校生活を送っているかお話しし
たいと思います
まずは
国際を日本チームさくら店でしたでの活動
について紹介したいと思います
私は
チーム桜田歯科に高校入学と同時に参加し
ました福田店ですかロボコン
チームですロボットを作ってロボットに
よる
競技大会に参加します
私たちが参加しているのはアメリカの
ファーストという団体によるFRCという
大会です
つまり大会の舞台は日本ではなくアメリカ
にあります
FRCに参加するチームはアメリカ国内を
中心に世界の様々なところから集まってき
ます
このFRCが他のロボコンと違う点は
FRC
チームFRCではチームがどのように
スポンサーを獲得し
チームで若者の一員教育にお広めることに
携わっているかという社会貢献活動を
とても大きく時代している点です
FRCでは実際にインパクトアワードと
呼ばれるショーがありその勝負はこういっ
た社会貢献活動がどれくらい行われている
かによって消化与えられます
ちなみに私たちは過去に2回この賞を受賞
しております
このようにサクラテンペストではロボット
政策に加えて資金集めアウトリーチ活動
この3つによって
活動が構成されています
これを聞くと私が外とハーブやソフトなど
の
技術的なことに
精通しているように思うかもしれませんが
私も最初は全くの初心者でした
このチームに入ろうと思ったのはアメリカ
から取得した際に英語を活かしたり世界と
つながるような団体に出社は一体なと思っ
たことがきっかけでし
たサクラテンプレストはFRCに参加して
いることからロボット政策以外の広報だっ
たりイベント運営だったり様々な活動が
あり運営サポートメンバーを必要とする
ことから
参加することを決めました
私たちのチームは
完全に中高生が主体となって運営されてい
ますその中で私は広報企画部門リーダー
そしてSNSの往来をしたりスポンサーと
もフォローアップをしたり新規質問者の
開拓をしたり広報関係の仕事をまとめてい
ます
ここで一つ質問ですが私たちがさくら専門
家として活動をするのに年間約どれくらい
のお金がかかるでしょうか
私たちのロボット政策はもちろんイベント
開催や大会徒歩それを全て含めると年間約
400万円ほどかかるのですそして私たち
はその資金を全て
防災企業の方からの支援で運営しています
つまりこのチームではメンバーからの参加
費
活動費などは全く取っておりません
この資金ですが
海外のチームからすると海外では
企業が中高生に支援をするのはかなり
当たり前になってきていますが日本では
なかなかそういった
姿勢が一般的ではありませんなので新しい
スポンサーを開拓するのは様々な苦労が
あります
こういったスポンサー企業とのやり取りは
高校生活の中では普段味わえないすごく
貴重なものだと思っています例えば自分の
名刺を持ったり
支援をしてもらうために交渉する
ミーティングに出たりと時に自分がこの
社会人になってしまったのではと思うこと
もあります
企業の方々も私たちを中高生のように扱う
のではなく台頭に接してくださいます
ミーティングの中で様々な意見を交換し
たり時に鋭い
鋭い意見を言われることもありますこの3
つの活動を通して私たち中高生は学校では
選べない様々なことを学んでいます
この桜展示した中で私が最もやりがいを
感じていることは
理系経営を小中高生に広める活動です
私たちは毎年のようにこのようなロボット
ワークショップをスポンサー企業の共催し
ています
海外のチームと交流すると日本の学生に
とって
理系の
精神医学のハードルが高いと思われてい
たり男女格差があったりするという事実に
気づくことができました
私たちが行っている
ワークショップの一つとして
移行チャレンジというものがあります
旅行チャレンジでは女子にターゲットに
絞って女子中高生を対象にロボットや
プログラミングをキット作りやゲームなど
を通して楽しく教える
ワークショップです
これは全国の女子に平等にこの
提供するために
完全に無料で行っています
今年の曲をチャレンジの後には2名の参加
者がこれからももっとロボットやっていき
たいと桜展でしたチームのメンバーとして
参加してくれることになりました
このようにこれからも日本日本での
日系人学への普及特に女性へのようにこの
引き出していけるように
努力を重ねていきたいと思っています
そして実際のFRCでは私は主に
インパクトアワード先ほど紹介した
インパクトアワードに携わっております
この商品はこの賞は社会貢献活動で評価さ
れるのでそれに提出するそれを紹介する
英語でのエッセイや
活動報告記録書の執筆それから大会の会場
で実際に写真のように行われる
プレゼンテーションの準備を説明者として
行っています
もちろんここでは英語スキルというのを
重要になってくるのですがそれ以外にも
プレゼン
能力人に何かを捨てる能力やメンバーの
マネジメント能力など様々なスキルが必要
になってき
桜テンペシアは和心チームであると聞くと
やはり
理系に特化しているように見えてしまうか
もしれませんが実は
ITやエンジニアリング以外にも法人運営
だったり
マーケティングだったりSNSに運用だっ
たり様々なスキルが必要になってきます
またこういう活動につながることで例えば
理系進学が日本で少し遅れているなど日本
のこれからも課題について日頃から意識
することにもつながっています
次にお話ししたいのが
リーダーシップを大切についてです
これは私がアメリカで中学時代を過ごした
ことから言えることでもありますが
アメリカでは小さい小さい頃から人前に
立って発表したり
プレゼン能力を育てる機会がとても多いと
感じましたこれはアメリカ人が自分の言い
たいことをちゃんと視聴できるそういった
文化の人にもなっているのだと思います
アメリカの大学進学入試では日本とは少し
異なり学校での成績のほかに
その高校生の間にどういったボランティア
活動をしたかや
リーダーシップの経験があるかということ
も評価の対象に入って
そこで私が選んだのがボーイスカウトです
ボイスカートには最高ランクである
イーグルを目指すために様々な行いを
こなしていきますその中の一部としてタイ
の中でリーダーを務めないとイーグルには
なれない仕組みになっています
私は現在自分のボーイスカウトの際の
リーダーをやっていてそこでの
リーダーシップの経験はこちらのサクラ
テストでの活動に生かされています
このような民間刑事に通じて私が感じた
ことというのは人の上に立つというのは
自分で全部の仕事の責任を負うのではなく
人を動かすことそしてそのチームとしての
パフォーマンスを最大化することにあるの
ではないかということです
初めて私がサクラテンペストでロボット
ワークショップの
リーダーを任された時は自分ですいろんな
仕事を抱え込んでしまって
チーム内でのコミュニケーションがうまく
いかなかったりそのせいでイベントの内容
がいろんな人に伝わらなかったりという
こともありました
大きなプロジェクトを動かすというのは
自分一人の力でできるものではありません
必要になってくるのは全体を動かすこと
そのチームメンバーの個性を
理解してそれをどうやって
活かしていくのかということを考えるそれ
が真のリーダーシップではないでしょうか
私が参加している作曲店でしたそして
ボーイスカウトは共に大人の方のサポート
を受けながら
失敗することが許容されている環境です
失敗とは悪いことと捉えるのではなく
経験値として
捉えてみるのはどうでしょうか
今どれだけ失敗できるか逆に今もっと失敗
しておいた方が将来の成功につながると
思います私はそう考えてどんどん挑戦して
ロングに失敗してどんどん学んでいってい
ます本日最後にお話ししたいの
はっていう言葉についてですこれは自分が
心地よいと感じる環境から出るという意味
になります
私がいる佐倉店でしたでも美味しかった
それらは最初から私にとってコンフォート
ゾーンだったわけではありません
チームに入った当初は技術のことや何も
分からずメンバーの会話についていくこと
すら大変でしたボーイスカウトでも活動は
完全に英語で行われているため帰国子女で
はありますが
文化の違う人たちをまとめるというのは
簡単なことではありませんでした今皆さん
の高校にて自分の居場所があって心地よい
なと感じているかもしれませんですがその
コミュニティから一歩出るか自分の居場所
は最初から用意されているわけではないの
ですそしてその居場所というのは自分で
作る
ことが大切です
そして自ら飛び込むことで
成長を加速することもできます
皆さんも高校生活の3年間時間的猶予を
活用して
今後のゾーンから飛び出してみませんか
ミーティングしていくプロセス活動にこの
失敗することは
霊長の家庭だという言葉に沿って私はこれ
から
挑戦して
失敗して学びを続けていこうと思いますご
静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]
[音楽]